today's our Thursday conference and our
speaker is well known to most of use
she's been around the department for a
number of years now and for those who
don't know this talk is the first step
in the ph.d program that the student
does in terms of giving a symposium kind
of overview of what they're interested
in that will later progress into their
proposal dissertation proposal defense
and then ultimately their dissertation
defense so Rory blue Turk who many of
you know is hails originally from Alaska
although she's been in Portland a number
of years did her undergraduate work at
the University of Portland and she's
been a PhD student in NLM predoctoral
trainee in our program so I will send it
her all right thanks Bill thank you so
much for coming today to listen to my
symposium presentation the title of my
talk is predicting adverse drug
reactions from off target so there's two
key aspects to any drug one is how well
it works or its efficacy and the other
is it safety or tolerability for a
patient today we're going to be focused
on the safety arm of drugs so when we
talk about toxicity concerns oftentimes
we're talking about side effects or
adverse drug reactions we can use these
terms interchangeably side effects can
be good or they can be bad as far as
whether they're harmful or beneficial
but when we talk about predicting and
preventing adverse drug reactions we're
usually talking about the harmful ones
they range in severity so they can be as
mild as a headache or nausea or a severe
as organ failure and every year they
result in tens of thousands of
hospitalizations permanent disability
and death for patients so they present a
significant health care burden there are
also a major source of a trick
in the drug development pipeline so it's
estimated that we lose up to thirty
percent of our of our lead candidates
just to toxicity concerns and you
probably heard about them because
they're the reason for many famous
aftermarket withdrawals of drugs so a
famous example is vioxx which was in n
say that was on the market for about
five or six years and it was used to
treat arthritis and chronic pain but it
actually came out that it was increasing
risk of heart disease of heart attacks
so it was pulled after the fact so if we
think about side effects in terms of a
drug interacting with receptors we can
classify them in a couple different ways
the first would be the drug is
interacting with the primary target in
the primary tissue in the body it's just
that rather than having the therapeutic
effect that's intended either there's
too much or too little so an example of
this would be dosing for anticoagulants
there's a very narrow therapy therapy
utica window another class of side
effect would be the drug interacts with
the primary target but that target is
present in a different tissue in the
body so it has an unwanted side effect
an example of this is morphine axon
receptors in our brain to have a pain
killing effect but there are very
similar receptors to these in our gut
and that can cause constipation the
third class is what the focus of the
talk is going to be in that secondary or
off targeting so this is when the drug
interacts with receptors that are not
the primary receptor so a quick example
is the HIV drug rescript ER also causes
rashes because it interacts with an
alternative receptor lastly you can also
imagine that you can have side effects
due to interactions between these
different types of targets but today
we're going to focus on the third
category so to understand a little bit
about the context of off targeting most
of the history of drug design has been
really steeped in this paradigm that we
can design a drug to selectively bind to
a target and then that target will have
some therapeutic effect this is where a
lot of our attention has been
in this selective design but what we
found in recent years is that the truth
is is that drugs bind to multiple
targets and these targets can have
different effects so this is the off
targeting aspect that I just discussed
this phenomenon is known as poly
pharmacology and we're only just
starting to really recognize and try to
deal with it in both drug design and
just in giving drugs so what do we
currently do to identify off targets we
don't actually look for them directly
what we do is conduct the safety screams
in the drug development pipeline so
these are basically panels of targets
that we know are associated with
toxicity or some adverse event and we
check to see if our candidate drugs bind
Indian any of these targets so a great
example this is the herg receptor which
is a potassium channel that's been
related to adverse cardiac events and
this is actually one of the only
federally mandated toxic targets that
you have to screen your drug against but
you can imagine that you can't check
your potential drug against all protein
targets there's a lot in the human body
so these screens are limited by time
cost and resources what ends up
happening is that most adverse drug
reactions are identified once a drug is
already on the market and this is
definitely not ideal because that means
patients are already going to are taking
the drug and going to be experiencing
the reactions so there's definitely a
need for computational and predictive
models to help us identify these
reactions much earlier in the process
and just to give you an idea of where we
are we'd really like to use these models
in the preclinical screening process so
that's after we've identified candidate
compounds but before they've actually
entered into human clinical trials so
for the arc of this talk what I'd like
to do is go through some of the groups
of approaches as people have tried to
tackle this problem of can we predict a
drug side effects or adverse reactions
before they actually happen and so I've
grouped these approaches into a couple
different subsets and
we're going to start with approaches
that look at just the drug itself or
compound structure approaches and then
we're going to add on kind of like
another layer interactions between the
drug and the target and then we're going
to move up into network approaches and
lastly I'm going to discuss kind of an
alternative category which I've just
called phenotypic approaches for now so
approaches that consider just the
structure of a drug so also also call
them chemical structural approaches rely
on this principle that similar structure
implies similar activity so for those of
you that are familiar with Q shires or
quantitative structure-activity
relationships that's basically you play
this game of can we find the molecular
features in a chemical compound and
relate those to some activity oftentimes
this is used for toxicity prediction so
that's the same principle that we're
going to see in these approaches and
most of them utilize this idea of a
chemical fingerprint so this fingerprint
is just a vector of ones and zeros where
one indicate the presence of a
particular chemical group in the
compound and the reason we do this is
it's a really nice way to describe a
compound and then it lets us easily
compare compounds without actually
having to look at drawings or these 2d
descriptors so down here I've
highlighted a very famous similarity
metric called the Tana moto coefficient
and Tana moto just takes the number of
shared chemical group groups between
compounds and divides it by the number
of total groups so one of the strongest
examples of using this idea to predict
adverse drug reactions was by vendor at
all in 2007 and this certainly wasn't
the first group to do this but they were
the most large-scale study and what they
wanted to do was see whether you could
use chemical structure to predict a dr's
across across many drug classes and many
reaction classes so they really wanted
to broaden scope to see if this
relationship held true because up until
this point this approach had really only
been used for very focused studies on
drugs or particular toxicity reactions
and so what they did is they could they
created two models one where they
related chemical structure to activity
against targets another one where they
created a model relating chemical
structure to adverse reactions and then
they use this to create a bridge between
the activity against the targets and the
adverse reactions and this did pretty
well when it came to classifying off
targets as being related to known
adverse events they had about ninety to
ninety two percent accuracy so that
works spurred a lot of follow-on work in
the same vein and most papers that use
this chemical structural similarity
approach are going to cite that paper as
paving the way for them or showing that
this is a good tactic to take and so
rather than go through those because
they use the similar ideas I wanted to
highlight something interesting that has
come out of this work and I think it's
best shown by this group year it's very
recent who basically asked the question
well what's the difference of looked
between looking at the 2d structural
similarity and the 3d structural
similarity and they posed this example
of let's say you have two compounds that
look very dissimilar at the 2d level but
in fact when you look at their
three-dimensional shape they're very
similar and so this might be important
because if we use 2d similarity metrics
we're going to miss it but in fact the
3d similarity could mean that this these
two drugs bind to the same type of
target protein and briefly what their
model did is they set it up so that they
could take some query compound and
compare that compound to a set of
compounds that have a known effect they
did this using both 2d and 3d and what
happens is if you find that your query
compound is likely to be a part of a set
then you infer that it has a shared
target so you can imagine that they did
this for compounds who they already knew
what the off target was and tested to
see if they could recover that
information so that's a very common
tactic and a lot of these approaches
what they found was very interesting
because
they showed that 2d similarity is
awesome for predicting primary targets
of drugs but 3d similarity is better
when it comes to predicting the off
target or the secondary effects and
their explanation really stuck with me
because what they said is we're dealing
with a bias in the data especially for
the 2d structure and that's because of
these neat to drugs so what happens in
drug design is it takes a lot to get a
drug from start to finish and when one
finally makes it out the pipeline you
see a lot of follow-on drugs that are
designed basically to mimic that
compound and then they postulated that
maybe 3d similarity is better at
capturing information about off targets
because 3d similarity may be capturing
information about actual binding pocket
features so chemical structure
approaches definitely make up the bulk
of the approaches in trying to predict
adverse drug reactions for a given drug
but there's definitely some limitation
so the diversity of the datasets used a
lot of times they're very very specific
predictive models and it's not clear how
well they generalize to broader classes
or how they'll work on truly novel
compounds since most of them are tested
on drugs that are already out there like
we talked about there's this inherent
bias especially in the structure the 2d
structural data for drugs because of
follow-on me to drugs and then really
there's this question of whether this
approach is the strongest one to take
this assumption that similar structure
means similar activity doesn't always
hold true in fact there's many examples
of molecules that are very similar as
far as their structure but they have
completely different effects so some
people are not convinced that this is
even the way to catch all the off
targets and also this view is limited
and that it only looks at properties of
the drug itself so what happens if we go
up a level and actually start looking at
the drug interacting with the protein
binding pocket so these are kind of what
I've classified as like in protein
interactions and you can imagine when
that drug comes in to bind with
pocket there's all different sorts of
interactions that can happen I've listed
just a few like hydrophobic interactions
water molecule displacement salt bridges
and there's approaches that try to take
this into account when predicting
adverse reactions and two of the main
types you'll see our protein ligand
interaction fingerprints and those use
the same idea as the fingerprint we
talked about before only instead of
keeping track of the chemical groups
they keep track of these interactions
and then something you might all be a
little more familiar with is docking
approaches or virtual screening so this
is commonly used in just traditional
drug design and the idea is that you can
take a panel of small molecules drugs
and actually virtually virtually
simulate them fitting into a protein
target and this allows you to come up
with a score and say well this is a good
match we think this binding reaction
occurs and then you can then test it so
like I said this is used in drug design
a lot but it has now started to be
picked up for possibly predicting off
target reactions because you can imagine
that you could take a drug structure and
you know the drug is associated with an
ADR and then you can try to find places
it binds using this and what's really
great about this approach is that allows
you to discover novel off targeting
combining reactions however docking in
particular is limited because you need
that 3d protein structure and at this
time we're still limited in the
availability of those so it really
depends on your use case and these
methods seem to do very well but it's
hard to compare them because they're so
variable in the features they take into
account how they score it and
restrictions they place on the whole
problem so one example is some docking
methods allow a drug to be very flexible
when it comes to a binding pocket and
others give it a rigid conformation and
then that's it so it can be very
difficult to really assess these methods
or compare them to each other and as
often times what you see is they can
should come up with different results
for these panels and well we've added
more information we're still treating
the drug target interaction as though
it's an isolated event so what happens
if we start to go up another level and
say there's more of a system behind all
of this and so this is what I've called
network approaches and what I the
distinction I want to make here is that
a lot of the network approaches are
really just approaches here there are
ways of connecting information rather
than using true molecular network
information so for example a lot of
these networks are constructed using
drugs as nodes and the connections
between the nodes maybe these drugs are
structurally similar for instance so
it's the same principles we just talked
about you could also do this for targets
and connect targets based on similarity
or some of the networks connect make
connections between drug nodes if they
share a target this one in the
background here is an example of a drug
target Network and this was done using
all the fda-approved drugs and they're
known targets and while this didn't
actually connect to adverse reactions in
particular it was used as it was
basically the first example to do this
for all the fda-approved drugs and a lot
of the work in predicting adverse drug
reactions started from this and uses
some of the stuff they came up with but
what about actual what we think of like
true systems information so there's a
lot of interaction data such as
protein-protein interaction data and I
was really surprised to find that that
really hasn't been used in this problem
yet so one of the only examples that I
could find for example using
protein-protein interaction is by this
group playing at all and a couple of
years ago they did a network they create
a network approach where they connect
drugs and targets but then they expanded
their target Network to include all the
other proteins that a target protein
interacts with and they found that for
their machine learning approaches
including this information improve their
predictions but there's a couple papers
that they put out and that basically
comprises
all the work in this area that I found
so far and then one other thing I'd like
to mention is there was a group that
created a network of adverse drug
reactions connected to the protein
targets and started to expand that with
protein protein interactions but that
wasn't an all connected to the drug
which was very interesting so it
actually wasn't in this realm of
predictive models for a dr's so when we
go up to the network level it's really
surprising to find that most of these
approaches use this idea of a similarity
network they don't actually incorporate
molecular information so like I said
there's very limited use of
protein-protein interactions and another
thing is that there's almost no
discussion of what we think of as true
pathway effects so upstream downstream
basically directing those edges between
nodes and then for the last group of
approaches I'll talk about is this
phenotypic approaches and I just like to
highlight an example that has tried to
use gene expression profiles for this
problem so this work builds off of
connectivity map and connectivity map is
a database that has data from human cell
lines that's been treated with drugs and
one of their key ideas is that we can
define a DS a disease state or condition
based on this profile and then using
that profile we can find a match or a
drug that has the opposite effect so if
you imagine that a disease state
upregulates a bunch of genes their
suggestion is well let's find the drug
that down regulates those genes so we
can restore balance so this group worked
off of connectivity map data and their
idea was well let's say drugs bind to
the same target that target should be
affecting the same downstream genes so
we should see very similar expression
profiles and in fact they found this was
the case so what this allowed them to do
was say well we can look for similar
expression profiles for two compounds
and infer that they then share the same
target this was all
a setup for their work to try and
associate adverse drug reactions with
gene expression profiles so what their
method did very briefly is they took a
query compound and compared it to a set
of reference compounds which we've seen
before only now instead of using
structural similarity they did this on
the basis of the gene expression profile
and their reference compounds were all
compounds that have a known associated
adverse drug reaction so they use this
to basically say for some query compound
what's what's the likelihood or what's
the risk is it at risk for any of these
adverse drug events to wrap up I'd like
to finish with a case study that I think
highlights a lot a lot of the concepts
we've touched on throughout the talk and
this is for tor setrákus so this was a
cholesteryl ester transfer protein
inhibitor and it was designed to treat
high cholesterol and prevent heart
disease and it was very very promising
until it reached phase 3 clinical trials
when it was withdrawn abruptly and it
was a big surprise to everyone involved
because it had fatal side-effects I was
causing heart attacks and one of the
reasons it was so surprising is there
were two very similar compounds and
structurally similar compounds that
didn't show these effects and that had
also seen promising so everyone was kind
of blindsided by this and this case
study is about a group that said well
can we interrogate the off targets and
trying to understand what went wrong
here and why this happened so what they
did is they said well we know it's a
cetp inhibitor and we know the primary
target so they characterized that
binding site and then they basically
just search for that elsewhere in the
human proteome and then they took all of
those places and said these are
potential off targets where towards the
trip it may be binding and then they
further refine that by running the
virtual screening or docking simulations
on both tour cetera Pibb and these two
similar compounds to actually see how
well the match was
and long story short what they found is
this idea that these compounds so very
similar at one level actually at very
different binding profiles when you
looked at their off targets so here the
arrows are indicating binding to off
targets shown in the yellow boxes red is
strong purple is not as strong and blue
is very weak so when they actually put
these off targets into a context and ask
what they did they found that all the
off targets on the left side are
positive regulators of a system that
controls blood pressure and the one on
the right is a negative regulator so the
important point here is for such rip it
binds very strongly to the positive
regulators and it basically ramps the
system up whereas jtt 705 which is one
of the compounds that didn't show the
negative side effects binds to both the
positive and the negative regulators and
probably is causing some sort of a
balance so they hypothesize that because
for such a pub is binding to off targets
in this balances and holding that's why
we're seeing these disastrous side
effects and another thing that's
interesting from this example is that
you'll note that jtt 705 actually binds
to more off targets and this goes
against a lot of our thinking because we
tend to think of off targets as
inherently bad but it's really what
they're doing in the long game and I
just thought that was an interesting
point and so I think this case study
really illustrates the need for context
of these drug target interactions and I
think it's a very successful example of
why or how this information can help us
really understand how that drug is
eliciting these reactions so just to go
over some of the main points again
there's a lot of structural approaches
when it comes to treating this problem
but they suffer from a lack of diversity
in the drug data especially approved
drug data there's definitely this
inherent bias and 2d structure due to
these me to drugs and then there's
authors also this question of whether
similarity
approaches are the best way to tackle
the problem given that not all similar
molecules have a similar effect and
there's been quite a few docking
approaches which seem to do very well
but they're limited by the presence are
the availability of those 3d crystal
structures and they're highly variable
so it makes it hard to compare and
really quantify how well they're doing
and overall structure is really only one
piece of this puzzle but it makes up the
bulk of the work and tackling this
problem when we go up a level and you
would or at least I would expect to see
more work in actual systems approaches
we really don't see a lot there's a lot
of network approaches but they're using
the similarity metrics in some way or
another and there's been very limited
use of protein-protein interactions and
almost no characterization of downstream
effects and very limited use of gene
expression profiles and in particular
when it comes to the protein-protein
interactions or downstream effects this
is interesting because it means that
we're really focused on the drug binding
to the off target and that off target
having to be directly connected to the
adverse drug reaction we haven't really
expanded to include more about whether
that off target starts a signaling
cascade and how that could lead to the
adverse reaction and so I think what all
those highlights is really that we're
missing the context and what the case
study I think highlighted so well is
that's going to be absolutely crucial
for understanding how these reactions
actually take place and hopefully not
only predicting them but preventing them
for the future so with that I'd like to
thank my advisor Shannon and glomming
and also Karen for being on my faculty
and the demise faculty students staff
and fellows and everyone who attended my
practice talk thank you very much and
especially Ted for helpful comments I'll
kick questions
yeah that's interesting i wonder if if
you could say a little bit more about
your gold standard data as to i assume
that you're running these algorithms
against some kind of data of known
adverse reactions to these drugs in
humans i assume i just wonder if you
could just say a lot more to that we can
to understand how you're measuring when
you're achieving success in predicting
yeah so that's that's a really great
point it's different for a lot of these
methods which is another problem a lot
of these methods are tested by asking if
you can recover off targets that we
already know exists and so those are
recorded side effects and adverse of
expert approved drugs so one of the
databases they use is cider which is
just a listing of drugs and all the side
effects that have been associated with
that drug so that is a yes then so hot
and then what what metrics do you use to
measure you know how well your
predictions are so usually it's just
done with like a area under the curve
and whether they come up as associated
with that adverse event so and usually
it's just um sonya through your question
yeah you know I'm just always interested
in you know when we apply these
predictive methods how we actually
measure how well they work because yeah
you know for example with any kind of
clinical data there's always some
inherent either ambiguity or missing
data and things like yeah so a lot of
these methods focus on very
well-established adverse reactions and
so they're going to they'll be at those
that have shown up in so many people
from the population the rare ones
haven't really been focused on it seems
like unless the work is specifically for
that but that does bring up another
issue is that a lot of times these just
focus on a class of adverse reactions
and so they don't inherently take it
count severity for instance so it's not
a lot of them don't actually use
reported from specific patients veena
once you're able to add in the context
how do you anticipate this will change
on drug discovery or clinical use
hopefully in a big way I think that
that's a nice question thank you I think
that a lot of these models really suffer
because they're not I don't feel like
they're actually translational or
getting anywhere they they have anywhere
from sixty to ninety percent and present
for predicting these off targets and
these adverse reactions but then you
don't see that carried any further as
far as can we actually use this in drug
design as far as I can tell we aren't
really using these models in a rigorous
way to try and predict side effects for
drugs and I think actually putting it to
use is still missing so ideally it would
be something like that dreaming big yeah
I wasn't hardened but more than personal
great talk really really good ones that
strikes me you're talking about the
structural and gawky models and one of
the big issues we have is the drug drug
interactions yeah it's a great point and
so in one of the causes what is that one
drug can change the confirmation of the
target molecule doing these models take
that into effect actually looking at
different changes of the confirmation no
none of these models that I've discussed
have gotten to that they're really
starting with the simple case of the
binding pocket as it's fully
characterized but that's a really great
point and something that is very closely
related to this I think it is because
it's just there's so much yeah there's a
lot going on thank
okay uh-huh yeah so that one I think
they are mostly focused on polarity and
I think they also took into account
displacement of water molecules in the
binding no that wasn't the interaction I
no polarity was taken into account but
they basically just tried to come up
with the 3d shape and one of the things
i think they specifically checked for is
whether there was the presence of like
bulky groups that might take up space
but I'll have to look into that a little
wine what you thank you
any of their questions all right thank
you so much for your time I appreciate
it